Let's talk about the economy a little bit.
Um, Donald Trump loves to talk about the stock
market on days that the stock market goes
up.
Sort of like today, looks like it's going
to be, but on days when the stock market is
down, like last Friday when the Dow Jones
industrial average was down 600 points, Trump
says nothing about it.
Sometimes on a down day, Trump will actually
say, you know, I don't really pay attention
to the stock market, which is an obvious lie.
It's very similar with GDP.
GDP is gross domestic product.
It's another indicator that Donald Trump has
talked a lot about.
He's predicted and promised 4% 5% even 6%
GDP growth.
Those numbers were pretty crazy to begin with
and it's bearing out that Trump can't meet
them.
And it turns out that fourth quarter GDP in
2019 went up 2.1% full year, 2019 GDP was
just 2.3%.
That's the lowest in three years.
Now, at a systemic level, we should be asking
questions like, what does GDP tell us about
an economy and what doesn't it tell us about
an economy?
There's a lot that GDP doesn't tell us about
the state of the economy.
What other indicators are important to understand
how the economy is doing for the average person,
just GDP doesn't tell us in the same way that
you know the stock market level doesn't tell
us you need other indicators.
These are good important questions, but we
also have to talk about accountability and
holding politicians to what they say.
Trump has been promising for years and the
white house has been predicting for years,
including for 2019 higher GDP numbers.
They failed to get them.
Now we can go further.
One of the defenses of the 2017 tax reform
that Trump and Republicans passed was it might
look like it'll cut revenue to the government,
but it's going to be so stimulative to the
economy that GDP will go up, tax revenues
will go up.
We're going to win hugely.
None of that happened, but the super rich
still got their tax cuts, which we knew they
were going to get.
For the most part, Donald Trump ignores bad
GDP numbers and if you press him, he will
do what he's done his whole career.
He'll blame somebody else lately.
He blames the federal reserve.
He says, you know, the federal reserve helped
Obama hugely with low federal funds, interest
rates.
They're not helping me.
The reality is the fed has kept rates quite
low.
The fed has done some decreases to the federal
funds rate.
Trump blaming the fed is another way to shift
the blame to someone, to anyone else.
And by the way, who's in charge of the fed?
It's the guy that Donald Trump selected.
So then remember when we look at GDP, we also
want to look at the deficit.
And once again, because Donald Trump has put
so much stock in the deficit, he said he was
going to get us a surplus.
The surplus would pay off the national within
eight years.
That's a joke.
Some of his followers fell for it.
The federal budget deficit is actually up
more than 20% from 2018 to 2019.
So if we want to step back from the day to
day politics, one of the the relationships
we want to look at is how is GDP growth comparing
to deficit growth.
Some so-called deficit Hawks always say if
the deficit is up, it's bad.
They don't say it when a Republican is president,
but that's okay.
They say it basically at all other times.
Um, the reality though is if you want to have
a more sort of nuanced understanding of a
deficit, you want to look at how deficit is
changing in relation to GDP.
They don't tend to care about that when it's
a democratic president.
Deficits bad.
When it's a Republican president, we don't
talk about deficit deficit up.
That's bad debt up.
That's bad.
Unless it's a Republican president in which
we are in case we only talk about GDP numbers
or whatever.
So let me give you the non political analysis.
Okay, I'm ignoring party.
I don't care about party.
I'm giving you a political and a non political
economic analysis.
As far as GDP growth goes, 2.3 is really not
bad.
Okay.
Just because Trump predicted more doesn't
mean 2.3% GDP growth is bad.
I would prefer 2.3 instead of these boom bust
cycles that are endemic to the type of economy
that we have.
2.3 is not bad.
The real question is one that nobody who is
prominent in American politics in a position
of power right now is actually asking and
certainly not one that the media is giving
attention.
Uh, paying attention to which is, is this
sustainable to have an economy based on infinite
indefinite growth on a planet that at some
point is going to reach the limit of its resources?
And by the way, what are we going to do to
our environment if we actually strip the planet
of all of those resources and burn them and
consume them and whatever else?
That's the real question.
It's almost a completely ignored by both parties
and in the same way you know, the size of
the deficit.
It's a very amateurish thing to look at.
The size of the deficit doesn't tell us that
much.
The real question is why is the deficit going
up?
If it's going up, is the deficit going up
because of inflation?
Is the deficit going up because we're financing
healthcare and education, which are very good
for a lot of people and stimulative to the
economy or is the deficit going up to pay
for the military industrial complex and you
know, foreign military entanglements and tax
cuts for the rich which are stimulative to
the very few people that are getting the cash
in their pockets but not by and large great
for the economy.
These talking points on economic issues all
almost always fall completely short of really
informing anyone, not even about what the
answers are.
They are asking the wrong questions.
They are predicated on a limited, if not completely
wrong understanding of what it is that we
should be paying attention to.
The GDP stuff is no surprise.
But of course, at the surface level, Donald
Trump making promises he simply cannot, cannot
keep and which his followers will almost certainly
not hold him accountable for